[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à tour pauline la future pâtissière veux
en savoir plus sur une recette typique
le nougat
alors du coup je vais rejoindre jean
marie qui m'attend près d eux au coin
des halles
donc normalement ils m'attendent avec sa
jolie tenue je vais voir ça tout de
suite
jean-marie soigner et le grand maître de
la confrérie gourmande du véritable
nougat de tours
ils sont aujourd'hui une quarantaine de
dignitaires et près de 700 chevalier et
officier à promouvoir ce petit trésor
culinaire à tensions apparues au moyen
âge est très populaire à la renaissance
le nougat avait disparu dans les années
70 pour la confrérie un seul combat le
faire connaître
du coup là on est devant la tarterie la
partie et des pâtisseries et pâtisseries
qui sont labellisés par la construire on
va voir ça tout de suite alors une égale
de tous ces dons une pâtisserie avec une
taille que tout le monde respecte de 18
cm d'accord qui est donc composé d'une
marmelade d'abricot avec des fruits
confits les fruits confits c'est du
melon et au dossier vous avez dans le
macaron demain d'auzat membres après la
théorie place à la pratique
direction le laboratoire du chef
pâtissier thierry guignard on se
retrouve en cuisine pour maintenant
offert un nougat ton et je suis
accompagné de thierry chef pâtissier non
mais je voulais juste dire que oui on
parle pas de cuisine en parle d'un
laboratoire ont pratiquement je suis en
apprentissage donc c'est parfait il faut
me reprendre premier cours avec un pro
pour l'élève pauline dans un premier
temps on va voir comment faire le fond
de pâte en fait le fonçage l'exercice
est plus difficile qu'il n'y paraît
le stress du pâtissier parce que en fait
c'est la première fois que je patine
avec un vrai pâtissier et du coup ça met
un petit peu la pression donc après
avoir monté les blancs en neige
il faut déposer la marmelade d'abricot
pourtant le droit de tourner et on
certain ça tourne
oui c'est vrai puis le melon confit
bah voilà
[Musique]
alors là va falloir regarder la pression
je vous avouerai que ça ça vient pas
tout de suite ça pas nourrir
donc tu vois on sucre une fois ça va
permettre de caraméliser un peu votre
vie mais j'ai essayé et ça ça sert
uniquement à faire le perlage 35 minutes
plus tard le premier nougat de tours de
pauline est prêt on n'a pas de la
marmelade les fruits confits et la
macaronade le moelleux on sent bien et y
amène le bruit à l'extraordinaire c'est
vraiment très très bon c'est très
moelleux c'est hyper fondant ça m'a
rassuré un peu aussi parce que du coup
j'ai pu voir les petites techniques que
je savais pas encore vraiment maîtrisé
tu es bien porter c'est vrai on continue
comme ça ça me rassure il n'y a pas que
nos gars tour sur le service
non justement
on